MIHAI IONESCU: Hello,
everyone.
Welcome to Payments Live.
We have an office hours slide
show today, answering
questions from Stack Overflow
groups and the moderator.
But before doing that, we'll
do something special.
Here in the studio with me
is my colleague, Peng.
Peng.
PENG YING: Hey, how's
it going?
MIHAI IONESCU: Say
hey to everyone.
And what we are doing is, as
we are getting close to the
end of a great year for Google
Payments and Wallet APIs, and
since this will be the last
show until next year, we
thought let's do a recap of all
the important events and
launches that happened
in 2012.
So let's get started.
Just as we crossed into 2012, we
launched the international
introduction of the
digital goods API
or the In-App Payments.
And that came with the
availability in 18 countries
and nine currencies.
And it was a nice,
new present.
And we made quite a [INAUDIBLE]
developers very happy.
Pong, what happened next?
PENG YING: And shortly after we
launched that, we also made
a few additional improvements
[INAUDIBLE].
We've added a streamlined
sign-up.
We call that [? mailing ?]
address sign-up.
And it makes it a very seamless
experience to
purchase virtual goods
from within the app.
So we simplified sign-ups
for in-app payments.
MIHAI IONESCU: So now even
the sign-up was in-app.
That's pretty cool.
And along the way, we also
had some cool developer
conferences and events, where we
met a lot of developers, we
talked about the multi-synch
apps, the Google Wallet.
And among those, some of the
most important work, the
Google Developer Conference,
[INAUDIBLE]
Conference, and South
by Southwest.
Both happened in early spring.
And they're coming again
this spring in 2013.
And we may have some cool
things to talk about.
So stay tuned for the
announcements.
We try to post the
announcements in
advance on this show.
PENG YING: And then in March and
April, we also announced
mobile web support for in-app
payments to API.
And what this means is that you
can just integrate once,
and you will be able to accept
purchases on the desktop and
mobile devices while
on the mobile web.
We also launched a Google+ page
for Google Wallet to keep
you up to date on the latest
Google Wallet news.
And in June, at Google I/O, we
had a few other great new
announcements.
We launched subscription support
and a new pricing
structure with fees
as lows as 1.9%.
Oh, and we also announced Save
to Wallet for offers.
MIHAI IONESCU: Lots of
announcements at
I/O. That's very nice.
And then the summer came,
and what did we do?
We took a vacation?
Not really.
Just right after Google I/O,
we launched this show on
Google Developers Live.
It's an amazing way to reach
developers in all
parts of the world.
We hold office hours
and [INAUDIBLE].
We try to give you a sneak
preview into things to come.
And to name just a few, we
showed you the new Merchant
Center, and also the new
commerce [INAUDIBLE]
features.
And the all these are very nice
new features that will
come in the coming months.
PENG YING: And then in August,
we did something new.
We moved the concept of Google
Wallet into the cloud.
So now instead of digitally
representing your credentials
on your phone or your device,
we are now storing digital
representation in the clouds.
And the benefit of that is that
it's now accessible from
any device connected to the
clouds or even off-line
sometimes, depending
on the device, that
supports Google Wallets.
Anywhere you want to purchase
from, whether it's your mobile
phone, whether it's your tablet,
whether it's your PC,
on any purchase flow that
supports Google Wallet, you
can make a purchase using the
same credentials across all of
those things.
MIHAI IONESCU: That's
really cool.
That was one big step forward.
You used to have only one card
available on Google Wallet.
Now you can have any of them.
And the cloud gives you
so many more security
enhancements and new features.
And with all those things going
along, we kept in touch
with the developers through
our Payments Live show.
But we also like to
meet face-to-face.
And in early fall, we had quite
a few conferences, where
again we met with developers and
talked about Wallet APIs.
And we had a lot of what we call
[INAUDIBLE], sponsored by
Google and local developer
communities in Washington, DC,
and in Mountain View
California.
To all those people there,
if you're watching, hi!
Later on this fall, we met with
quite a few people in
Kansas City.
And these are all great ways
to connect with developers.
And we'll make sure to
let you know about
any upcoming events.
PENG YING: And finally, closer
to the end of year, we
announced a new mobile wallet
API for mobile web
transactions.
What it does is it enables OAuth
2 like access to carrier
credentials.
Currently, it's only available
to select merchants.
But we're accepting new
merchants every day, and you
can request to be a merchant
on our site at
developers.googl
e.com/wallet-online.
MIHAI IONESCU: And of course,
we kept announcing more and
more mobile devices that come
preloaded with Google Wallet.
And the last few we mentioned in
previous shows are from the
Nexus line.
Phones and tablets from
Samsung and LG.
And let's see.
So we got closer to the
end of the year.
What else?
Oh, on the developer support
front, we are now focusing and
have centralized the support
to Stack Overflow.
And this is where we'll
actually take
some questions today.
And on Stack Overflow, please
make sure you only use
technical questions.
Either too generic or not on
technical topics, they may not
be accepted.
PENG YING: Yeah.
They may get closed out
by the community or
down-voted into oblivion.
MIHAI IONESCU: Yep.
All right.
So what a great year.
With that, let's move on
with the Q&A section.
So let me start with
the first question.
We had quite a few on
Google Checkout.
And this one involves the
carrier-calculated shipping
API, a very nice feature
of Checkout.
And the question is, I'm
using the Checkout
carrier shipping API.
I have three shipping methods
set up, and they work fine.
I added a new set of products,
and for those, the Checkout
order page only shows the
default shipping costs.
So obviously, your
carrier-calculated shipping
methods are not applying
to these new products.
It should be relatively easy to
debug and test this in the
sandbox, because you can then
complete the entire
transaction.
You don't just stop
at the order page.
And then you can analyze the
shopping cart [INAUDIBLE]
Google to try to figure out why
only the default shipping
cost is applied.
But if you cannot do that, since
this is happening only
for those new items, that's a
pretty good indication that
there's something probably
wrong with those.
There's some missing or
incorrect data in the
inventory when you added
them to your database.
And to give you a way to start
investigating, please know
that carrier-calculated shipping
needs the item weight
in order to calculate the total
shipping cost, because
carriers calculate cost
based on weight.
And most likely, you
have weights
missing on those items.
And that's why by default
there is zero, and then
carrier-calculated shipping
will use the default cost.
And another thing to make sure
regarding to weights is that
the total weight of the package
will have to be at
least 1/4 pound in
order for carrier
calculated shipping to apply.
So if you have smaller items,
just set them to 0.25 pounds,
or 1/4 pound, and then the
shipping methods will kick in.
So I think, probably, this is
what's happening, and you'll
figure it out.
PENG YING: Yeah.
Seems like it.
I've seen a lot of issues, and
most of them are mainly around
the weight.
MIHAI IONESCU: It's
easy to miss.
And when you're adding new items
to inventory, it's easy
to miss the weights, or add
smaller weights than is
actually the case.
PENG YING: True.
I'll take the second question.
So I have trouble with
taxes in Checkout.
The taxes set in the Merchant
Center are not applied.
And then I've seen this a few
times before as well.
And what's typically occurring
here is that I'm guessing that
the merchant is using an
e-commerce platform.
And e-commerce platforms also
sometimes can include their
own tax rules.
And these tax rules are defined
within the shopping
cart XML that your platform is
sending over the Checkout and
overwrites the tax rules that
are defined within Checkout.
So you're probably seeing the
default tax rules that the
e-commerce platform
has provided.
To get rid of this or fix this,
you have two options.
You could either fix the tax
data or update the tax
[INAUDIBLE] within your
e-commerce platform, or you
could ask your e-commerce
provider how to remove the tax
rules from [INAUDIBLE].
MIHAI IONESCU: Makes sense.
Let me take the next one.
So the question is about
passing specific order
information and private merchant
information in a
Google Wallet transaction.
And I think we touched
on this topic before.
Most wallet APIs give you a way
to ask private merchant
information [INAUDIBLE]
back to you so that you cannot
associate that information
with the order.
So since this does not mention
the particular wallet API, let
me talk about two of them that
offer this capability.
For the digital goods API and
the In-App Payments API,
there's a field called "Seller
Data," where you can pass
private information.
Probably it's a good
idea to encrypt it.
And this information will be
sent back to you in the
postback or when the transaction
completes.
And you can use it to update
your inventory, your user
management information,
everything there.
And similarly, on the Checkout
side, there is a "Merchant
Private Data" field
in the XML.
Merchant-private-data.
You can search for it in
the documentation.
Which behaves in a similar way,
and you'll receive the
same data back through
the notification API.
So two different APIs.
Similar methods to handle
merchant information.
PENG YING: I'll take
the next one.
So how can I change the
order page to get the
customer on my site?
The guy in this one doesn't
really talk about the API or
what part of the order flow.
So I'll answer all of
the possibilities.
First off, in Checkout, there's
[? no ?] automatically
corrects everything.
So in order to get the customer
back to your page,
the customer needs
to take action.
If it's during the initial
checkout flow, where they're
still viewing the order on
Checkout, you could do find
and edit [INAUDIBLE], and then
that'll create a link on the
checkout page that will allow
the user to go back to your
site to edit the items
in their cart.
Once the user has completed the
purchase, you can define a
Continue Shopping URL, which
will define a link to direct
the customer back from the
receipt page to your site.
But if you're only selling
digital goods, you can use the
In-App Payments API or Google
Wallet for Digital Goods,
where the entire flow takes
place on your site, and you
won't have any of
these problems.
MIHAI IONESCU: Yeah.
Much, much easier.
PENG YING: I hope
that answers.
MIHAI IONESCU: Yes.
All right.
There's another one
about pricing.
Do you want to take it?
PENG YING: MIHAI IONESCU:
Oh, yeah.
So this one is actually
from Stack Overflow.
And it's a little bit
un-technical for Stack
Overflow, but we answered
it anyway.
In Google Wallet, I set the
price in US dollars, but I'm
selling digital goods, and
my customer might be
anywhere in the world.
Is there any way you see what
Google Wallet will charge in
localized currency?
So this is kind of the opposite
concept of how Google
Wallet works.
Instead of you setting a fixed
price as a merchant, and then
expecting Google Wallet to
translate it across various
currencies--
well, how it actually works is
that you set a fixed price in
that currency, and then we
translate it to US dollars, or
whatever your merchant account
is in, and then pay you out in
that amount.
So it's the opposite.
And what you should do is IP
geolocate your customer, then
define the market price of the
item in the geolocator
currency, and enable your
customer purchase that way.
With that, instead of maybe
one day your customer gets
charged $0.05, and then the next
day your customer gets
charged $0.25, it's just a fixed
amount the entire time.
And then that currency
conversion risk is
handled on your side.
MIHAI IONESCU: OK.
Let me take the next one.
This is also Checkout related.
Oh, that's quite a few of
Checkout questions.
It says, I'm using the Checkout
notification XML API,
and Google seems to be
delivering notifications not
in the order I expected.
For example, an order state
change notification will have
a new financial order state of
charging, and then immediately
after one proceeding, it had
already said it would charge.
So all the notifications
may come out of order.
And especially for order
state changes.
The only Checkout notification
that is guaranteed to arrive
in order, it's the new order
notification, which will
arrive first.
So you'll get that one, and then
you may get some order
state changes notification
in not the
order you're expecting.
Your solution sounds fine--
setting the state of the order
to the order state
notification with a high
serial number, it's OK.
PENG YING: And I'll take
the last question.
Is it possible to cancel a
subscription for a user
without issuing a refund?
So there was some confusion
about cancellations of
subscriptions and whether that
would automatically refund the
subscription amount or
the latest charge.
And we want to clarify that.
Cancelling a subscription--
well, all it does is
it prevents the
recurrences from occurring.
So if there was an initial
amount tied to that
subscription initiation,
then you can
also refund that amount.
But cancelling the subscription
won't refund the
subsequent orders.
So if you want to refund each
of those subsequent
recurrences, you'll have to go
into those recurrences, and
then cancel and refund those.
MIHAI IONESCU: All right.
Any more questions?
We got to the end.
PENG YING: I think that's it.
MIHAI IONESCU: That's it.
Lots of Checkout questions.
People are getting ready to sell
stuff for New Year and
Christmas, and all the
winter holidays.
So we hope we make money!
[LAUGHTER]
MIHAI IONESCU: Great.
So this, as we said earlier,
this is last
show for this year.
And we will see everyone
back in 2013.
We want to wish you
a happy New Year.
PENG YING: Yeah.
Happy holidays.
MIHAI IONESCU: Happy holidays.
And we'll see you in 2013,
PENG YING: See ya.
MIHAI IONESCU: Bye.